yeah he calls me to play pool and I'm
like I got to go live and and I don't
and I don't expect him to understand
that there's also things that I like say
to him and I'm not sure if he hears he
doesn't like I'll say things like I'm
losing my house and he'll be like oh but
just go play
pool it's not that funny sounds like a
horrible person sad that's so sad I like
that they're all just like that's David
no he's a horrible friend like Jason he
should have set you up nice after
everything you guys have been through I
don't know what or how but you should be
rich you should be rich too the fact
that you're like I got to do hours on
Tik Tok to pay my bills that's not